the u.s. is nearing a truly gruesome new
benchmark in the fight against the virus
100,000 dead USA today created a special
cover showing the faces of some of the
victims and we of course share their
stories every week in our lives to
remember series the virus has killed
around 99 thousand Americans across the
nation that is more than the number of
Americans killed in the Korean and
Vietnam wars combined and it could soon
top the u.s. u.s. death toll from World
War one Gale where the corona virus is
often compared to another global crisis
for more than a century ago starting in
1918 the Spanish flu killed around 675
thousand Americans senior political
analysts and 60 minutes correspondent
John Dickerson joins us now to offer
some perspective John Dickerson good
morning to you from my home to your home
this is one of those days where I'm
sorry there's no green room so I can
come in and greet you appropriately but
nobody better to talk about this than
you when it comes to history John
Dickerson so how does this crisis
compare to others in the past when you
look at it I'm glad you're here it's
kind of compare it's kind of a hybrid so
it's it's it is like war in the sense
that it is a national acute moment of
suffering it's like a disaster in that
we we are all witnessing this together
but it is very different in this moment
that we're in because of the media
environment we're in and there is a
federal expectation of response when you
talk about 1918 Woodrow Wilson it was
the president then never mentioned the
flu he got it but he never mentioned it
there was no expectation that was but
that was partially because he was a
tardy president but it was also there
was no expectation there would be a
federal response now there very much is
and we have cameras trained on the
presidency and on the executive branch
and there is an expectation and that's
why they trained for it in the Bush
administration in the Obama
administration and so it becomes a big
national political question and as you
know in our current moment that means it
gets a jaggedness that wasn't there
before yeah let's talk about the
executive branch John what's the what's
the mark of an effective leader during
these times
well there is kind of a playbook and you
see a lot of leaders across the world
and governor's benefiting from doing
three basic things they tell the truth
even if the truth is kind of brutal when
I've interviewed experts about these
disasters they say tell the people the
truth because even if it's hard people
appreciate that they also take
responsibility because that aligns
everybody in the same direction it tells
a leader tells their staff you can't
explain your way out of this don't spin
your way out of this you need results
and then the other thing is they inform
people because even if there is
uncertainty information helps people
feel control and people need to feel
control and certainty to eventually
someday start getting back to a more
normal kind of life if they don't feel
that certainty and that sense of control
then everything that feels heiwa sort of
well out of their control and that means
they're not going to be able to get back
to the to life as they lifted before so
John how does a good leader balance the
gravity of is the situation and trying
to give people optimism we saw stories
of people on the beach saying well the
president doesn't wear a mask why do I
need to wear a mask people are actually
saying that and following his example
well usually what a president does is
focus on two things unity we're all in
this together and also stitches the
current moment into the national story
why do they do that because
psychologists tell us that in these
moments where we are all experiencing
something brand-new and afresh the brain
reacts by wanting to fix it wanting to
flee it operates at a kind of hazardous
level what a president or a leader can
do is say look Americans have been
through tough times before we're all in
this together and that kind of brings
people together and makes it either
easier to endure this a president
obviously can't scare the country but
again the experts say that if you're
clear with people and you give them the
information even if it's bad information
they feel a sense of control over their
lives and control is the precondition to
getting through one of these things
because you feel some sense of tiny
certainty in what is a big huge moment
of uncertainty and so a president has to
balance those two things most important
though is giving people clearer and
clearer information so
that they can figure out how to plan for
their future because the future is the
thing that is so uncertain John we're
running out of time but we're 160 days
away from election how do you see
anything that you can compare this to
and how we moved forward well I mean
there have been big national moments and
the real test is looking after the are
in the in the Great Depression what he
did was not only rewrite the social
compact basically tell Americans this
proves that we are all in this together
but he then went the next step there's
something in disaster recovery where
they talk about build back better he
took that opportunity and said this has
exposed a lot of cracks in our culture
it is also elevated Beauty and humanity
and the American story let's take the
best and let's fix what's wrong that
should be the test of the this election
coming up yeah I like that let's take
the best thank you very much John
Dickerson and fix what's wrong